[Musique]
hier soir une frappe meurtrière a touché
la Pologne un pays frontalier de
l'Ukraine explosion dans un dépôt de
céréales le bilan est de 2 morts c'était
mes meilleures amies j'étais chez moi à
la maison et soudain j'ai entendu un
bruit très puissant une frontière
sensible à quelques kilomètres de combat
terrible qui fait l'objet d'une
surveillance toute particulière le ciel
à la frontière entre l'Ukraine et la
Pologne et l'espace aérien le plus
surveillé du monde d'origine de ce
missile reste encore flou mais en
Pologne l'état d'alerte a immédiatement
été renforcé une réunion d'urgence des
ambassadeurs de l'OTAN a été organisés
et Emmanuel Macron s'est même exprimé
des analyses sont en cours nous
coopérons avec la Pologne pour savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé
explosion d'un missile en Pologne
faut-il s'inquiéter des retombées
merci Bruno Clermont générale
spécialiste de des questions de défense
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs ce qui s'est passé hier
en Pologne et il s'est passé de une
montée en tension d'une guerre dans
laquelle jusqu'à présent aucun des pays
extérieurs à l'Ukraine n'avait été
touché donc le fait que domicile touche
le sol de la Pologne sans savoir leur
origine a créé naturellement une
inquiétude de la part des pays de l'OTAN
particulier de la Pologne qui était
concernés d'autant plus qu'il y a eu
deux morts donc c'est ça c'est cette
question qui a fait monter la pression
et la crise en fait a été résolue assez
vite la crise n'a pas duré longtemps
elle a duré quelques heures c'est ça
parce que très rapidement dans la nuit
même si l'annonce a été faite qu'en fin
de matinée aujourd'hui les pays de
l'OTAN avaient la certitude que ce
n'était pas un missile d'origine tiré
par la Russie alors c'est quoi
alors a priori parce que ce que dit le
temps c'est qu'il y a une très forte
probabilité donc on est dans la gamme
mais entre 99,99 et 100 c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal on n'est pas comme ça
c'est un missile de fabrication russe
parce que les Ukrainiens utilisent du
matériel de fabrication russe en fait du
matériel soviétique qui a été répartis
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie il y a 30
ans et celui-ci donc de fabrication
russe est un missile de la défense
anti-aérienne
ukrainienne tirée par la défense entière
ukrainienne pour essayer d'intercepter
soit un missile balistique soit un
missile de croisière qui attaqué la
ville de livres qu'on dévoile la
frontière la ville d'olive c'est pas
loin de la Pologne et ce site cette
défense à une cette batterie de défense
aérienne était installée probablement à
quelques kilomètres de la ville pour
protéger la ville de Liévin c'est la
ville qui est tout à gauche sur la carte
donc on voit c'est très très loin de la
Russie donc
tout est rentré dans l'ordre là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tout est rentré
dans l'ordre pas tout à fait pas tout à
fait sauf le président zenki qui est pas
d'accord ah d'accord il est pas d'accord
parce que dès le départ
enfin il remet en doute en tout cas il a
refait récemment le fait que
celui-ci n'est pas été tiré par les
Russes alors il dit Cecile n'est pas
ukrainien il a pas ukrainien et les
Russes et le fabrication russe là les
raisons mais dans dès le départ de la de
cette affaire là il a il a essayé
d'attirer l'attention sur les
difficultés que rencontrer l'Ukraine en
particulier ça s'est produit au moment
très particulier où il y a une centaine
de missiles qui frappaient les villes
ukrainiennes une centaine de missiles ça
fait des milliers de morts on le soit on
le saura pas mais ça fait des milliers
de morts une centaine de missiles donc
effectivement il est sous pression il
est sous pression pour les occidentaux
accroissent leur aide éventuellement en
rentrant directement dans cette guerre
donc c'est un peu ce qui s'est joué à
son niveau puis le chef d'État de
l'Ukraine lui il veut protéger l'Ukraine
je pense qu'il est il est pas il est
c'est pas illogique d'avoir une telle
attitude la la France elle en est où
dans dans cette histoire là la France de
cette histoire la France elle s'est
alliée sur ses partenaires de l'OTAN sur
ses affaires très particulière des
missiles donc dès le départ la ligne de
l'OTAN global et de la Pologne qui était
concernée te dire nous allons demander
une enquête sur le terrain pour savoir
ce qui s'est passé donc il y a une
enquête sur le terrain on est allé voir
où on voit le trou là on voit ses
cratères et en voyant le cratère on l'a
découvert des débris de ce qui avait
causé le cratère et on a assez
rapidement remonté le fait que c'était
pas un missile de croisière russe mais
c'était imbécile entier aérien les
missiles antiériens dans la zone il y a
que des Ukrainiens parce que quand vous
voyez la carte entre la frontière de
Live et le front vous avez zéro
d'ailleurs il y a pas d'activité il y a
pas de présence militaire russe ni
système de défense aériennes de ce
côté-là ils sont tous vous voyez dans la
partie qui est en orange donc il y a pas
un missile qui est capable de faire
anti-rien qui était capable de faire
1000 km qu'est-ce qui se serait passé si
ça avait été un missile russe ah ouais
ça c'est la bonne question c'est la
bonne question mais je pense que même
même dans ce cas-là le deuxième scénario
possible c'était que c'était ces fameux
missiles de Croyère et balest qui avait
débile en trajectoire et qu'il est passé
la frontière de 6 km si les Russes
veulent faire une provocation hein c'est
pas en frappant un champ avec de
malheureux d'agriculteurs qui sont dans
leur tracteurs c'est pas ça une
provocation donc je pense que les pays
de l'OTAN ce serait réuni aurait mis en
oeuvre ce qu'on appelle l'article 4
c'est-à-dire que les pays se réunit à
Bruxelles tous les affaires étrangères
ils disent on va se consulter pour
savoir quelle décision on va prendre
mais même cette dans ce cas-là l'article
4 n'aurait pas donné le déclenchement
l'article 5 qui est le début de la
guerre c'est ça
juste petite question moi j'en parlais
avec mes équipes ce matin on parlait de
du sujet etc il disait c'est incroyable
on s'arrête la va avoir une guerre
mondiale etc et je leur ai dit moi même
si c'est des missiles russes je suis
persuadé que voilà il va y avoir une
grosse enquête que tout le monde espère
que ce ne sont pas des missiles russes
et que on va voilà et on va on va semer
aussi le doute parce qu'on n'a pas envie
d'entrer dans une guerre mondiale pour
domicile comme il dit qu'ils ont été
dans un champ et il y a eu deux morts
quand même voilà mais c'est ce que je me
suis assuré que le des diplomaties
occidentales c'est la transparence avec
les soins que vous êtes on va pas
commencer à monter des histoires
baptiser des métiers Ukrainiens
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça
fonctionne il y a pas de complot il y a
pas de pots cachés et simplement le fait
que on analysait
l'environnement tel que j'ai décrit la
nature de l'arme son origine
l'environnement dans lequel il pouvait
évoluer c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas le
tirer de la Russie il faut bien le tirer
de quelque part et seul les Ukrainiens
ont ce type de missile alors pourquoi ce
missile n'a pas touché l'objectif c'est
que les missiles antiériens ils sont
tirés en salve sur des cibles qui
arrivent qui sont des avions ou des
missiles et puis si le missile ne touche
pas sur mon objectif normalement il
s'autodétruit l'opérateur qui a tiré le
missile autodétruit le missile la
visiblement soit c'est missiles ne
pouvaient pas s'autodétruire soit
l'opérateur ne l'a pas autodétruit donc
il a continué sa trajectoire en
balistique elle est allée tombée de
l'autre côté de la polygone évite de
taper sur le bras comme tous les coups
viennent de la Russie comme tous les
coups de la Russie comment ce tir a-t-il
pu
il faut imaginer la défense de Paris
avec des systèmes de défense
antiériennes qui font face à Marseille
par exemple et à ce moment-là on tire
les missiles en direction de de général
j'ai compris
non c'est pas ta
spécialités
c'est pas du tout incohérent non mais
laisse les questions de défense voilà
c'est le l'animateur de TPMP je
comprends que c'est compliqué je suis
conscient du fait que c'est compliqué
non non c'est compliqué
merci mon Général alors va arriver
est-ce que c'est une question
intéressante c'est une question pour
montrer que vous êtes intelligente et
que vous êtes journaliste pour aller
dans votre sens Cyril est-ce que
comme le dit Cyril on sent bien que de
toute façon tout le monde faire
parce que personne n'a envie de faire
une deuxième guerre mondiale et que donc
par définition
évoquer l'article 4 on va faire des des
tables rondes et des tables rondes des
tables rondes pour essayer de trouver
des parades pour ne pas rentrer en
guerre dans ce cas là s'il y avait eu le
doute il y aurait eu une discussion et
l'article 4 et qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais
c'est pas le cas il y a aucun doute il y
a aucun doute sur la la réalité de ce
qui s'est passé donc il y a pas de
manipulation en fait on peut toujours
imaginaire mais je vous dis qu'il y en a
pas après vous croyez ce que vous voulez
mais non mais ça va être non mais
attention attention
général moi je vous crois plus que
Matthieu Delon non mais il faut bien
voir que c'est extrêmement important ce
que c'est important parce que c'est
effectivement la sécurité du monde qui
est ton joueur si si c'est démontrer le
contraire ça sera pas la même décision
et je pense que dans ce contexte là les
dirigeants ne peuvent pas mentir on ne
peut pas mentir on ne peut pas il y a
des choses qu'on ne peut pas cacher
alors il y a le président Joe bide
déclaré qu'il est peu probable que le
projectile était tiré depuis la Russie
voilà plutôt tout le monde ne va pas
mentir le monde entier ne va pas mentir
merci général de nous donner des
éléments que vous voulez dire quoi vous
bah je voulais demander au général quand
même c'est bizarre mon général
sur incroyable talent et laisse la
guerre aux autres non mais laisse la
guerre en général non mais toi toi le
général il est spécialistes et toi non
mais tu as tu as fait tu as fait une
émission de faits divers sur cnews et tu
vas donner des conseils
en général c'est quand même bizarre
c'est la nuit que les Américains la
presse américaine a sorti tout de suite
avec des infos venant du gouvernement
américain mais non c'est paru s'ils ont
quand même voulu très vite sans preuve
visiblement parce que les premiers
articles étaient pas sourcés enterré
l'affaire l'Amérique a voulu te taire
qui a une possibilité que ce soit la
Russie mais tu vas avoir Béatrice sur le
dos
pour interpréter comme ça mais c'est pas
comme ça que ça s'est passé après mais
comment vous le savez en général mais
c'est il est général
je peux répondre rapidement
identifié et les gens sont déposés très
vite pour pouvoir
le trou d'ailleurs le trou c'est pas un
gros trou c'est pas un trou de missile
balistique ça c'est un petit cratère et
les missiles antiériens ils ont pas une
grosse charge immunitaire en fait la
charge militaire elle doit éclater pour
pour faire des décussions les débris qui
abattre les avions donc effectivement
ils sont allés sur place ils ont
constaté et rapidement je pense que les
analyses de de des équipements qui
avaient autour sont arrivés à la
conclusion que ce n'était pas russe hein
mais ils ont pas vous dire que c'était
ukrainien c'était la même chose voilà ça
ça on est dans effectivement dans la
dans la gestion de la relation avec
l'Ukraine qui reste quand même le pays
qui est attaqué